down and we always see just the top of
his head because he keeps sinking down
in his chair
so maybe now we'll get the full
levonaronian for this game
it has started it has started and we do
see a king's pawn opening
will magnus carson play spanish one of
his favorite openings where he played
the italian game
that we saw earlier in the clash between
the pogniacci and nakamura
magnus carlsen i mean maybe he doesn't
realize it's his move
just pausing there and okay he plays um
i mean this we call this the four nights
defense you can understand why
because all the four nights are out very
early in the game
so um four nights defense right now
there there are options you can aim
towards
opening up the center quickly which
magnus carlsen does um
we yeah again we call this the scotch
four nights
because uh the scotch is when you open
up the center very very quickly it leads
to a lot of trades
and here we see a set of knights have
left the board um will we see both sides
castle the king magnus carson here